And now the nominees for the
best political speech by an entertainment celebrity
Meryl Streep
Jesse Williams
Ashley Judd
That Sheriff from Stranger Things
The Less Attractive Zach Galifianakis
and the winner is
Less Attractive Zach Galifianakis
thank you thank you very much
you know takes a lot of courage to
stand up and say things
that everyone in the room already wants to hear
and I think we entertainment celebrities are
going to be vilified for our bravery
here tonight but it's our job to unify a
country that has been torn apart by hate
and ignorance and racism misogyny and
pickup trucks and domestic beer and
Waffle House and
stupid accents
how did our country become so divided?
its time now for us to join together as Americans
and destroy the other half of
America that refuses to believe
in what we believe in
we might fight for peace
and we must continue fighting
until mixed martial arts become fine arts
till Cracker-Barrels become Crate and Barrels
Till Fast and Furious 8 becomes
Hamilton 2
thank you very much for my award
thank you to the academy
#freepolanski